faster higher stronger it's an attitude
that pays both on and off the field
the world's 50 highest paid athletes
collected an astounding 2.97 billion
dollars before taxes and agents fees
over the last 12 months smashing last
year's record total by 8
the cutoff to make the top 50 rose from
34 million dollars last year to 37.6
million dollars the highest threshold
ever
here's a breakdown of this year's
highest paid athletes list by the
numbers
three athletes surpassed 100 million
dollars in total earnings this year
lebron james reached the milestone for
the first time on the forbes athletes
list while setting a record for an nba
player at
121.2 million dollars
lionel messi who led the list with 130
million dollars and cristiano ronaldo
who made 115 million dollars are each
five-time members of the century club
only seven other athletes have ever
accomplished the feat roger federer
floyd mayweather conor mcgregor neymar
dak prescott manny pacquiao and tiger
woods endorsement deals and other
off-the-field endeavors accounted for
1.06 billion dollars of this year's
record total beating the record 1.04
billion dollars posted by last year's
group
roger federer leads the way off the
field with 90 million dollars accounting
for almost all of his 90.7 million
dollar total
there are six first-timers on the list
including the nfl's josh allen stefan
diggs marshawn lattimore ryan ramczyk
and tj watt as well as boxer jake paul
nine sports are represented on the list
led by basketball with 18 athletes
football comes next with 14 honorees
followed by soccer boxing golf tennis
formula one auto racing baseball and
mixed martial arts
fourteen nationalities are represented
on this year's list
the u.s is home to 35 of the ranked
athletes the uk with tyson fury lewis
hamilton and rory mcilroy is the only
other country with more than one
the average age of the 50 athletes on
this year's list is 32 years old kylian
mbappe at 23 is the youngest one of
seven athletes in the ranking who are 25
or younger phil mickelson at 51 is the
oldest
jake paul's 12 month earnings totaled 38
million dollars 30 million from two
fights and 8 million outside the ring
the 25 year old youtube star made his
pro boxing debut less than two and a
half years ago naomi osaka's 12 month
earnings totaled 59.2 million dollars
just behind the 60 million she posted on
last year's list to set a record for
female athletes serena williams is the
only other woman to appear in the top 50
with 45.3 million dollars
you